why didn't rhaenys roast the greens well
Leonor ever row back home house of the
Dragon season 1 left fans wanting more
with several burning questions still
lingering after the finale
though his conflict avoidant frequently
ill and largely ineffectual as a leader
much of the story and House of the
Dragon season 1 still revolves around
viserys Targaryen he is to be fair quite
an interesting character a man wholly
unqualified to keep War at Bay but who
remains the only one in a real position
to maintain peace is he a hero certainly
not he led his delusions of foresight
and his desire for greatness push his
wife to her deathbed is he a villain not
necessarily he does keep the peace after
all and he stays loyal to rhaenyra until
the very end viserys is undoubtedly a
sympathetic figure but that doesn't make
him a great king repeatedly throughout
House of the Dragon season 1 we get
scenes debating this question what does
it mean to be a good King what does it
mean to leave a lasting Legacy
what will they say of me when the
histories are written a lover of History
viserys knows that his reign will never
become a great song in the end he only
wishes for the feuds within his own
house to be settled before his death of
course that doesn't happen his beceros
the king who held the peace or the king
who's in action led to widespread
Bloodshed ultimately that's up to the
viewer to decide
princess rhaenis Targaryen plays a
unique role in the story of House of the
dragon as the so-called Queen Who Never
Was she represents an alternate path
that Westeros could have gone down had
she been given the Iron Throne instead
of viserys things might have gone quite
differently for everyone involved she
clearly would have been a stronger and
more decisive ruler and she would have
set the precedent that women can reign
as well as men such a precedent surely
would have prevented the kind of schism
that takes place in the show right well
that's hard to say the truth is even if
Raines had been selected as Queen she
probably would have faced the same kinds
of challenges that rainyro faced
throughout season 1.
men would sooner put the round to the
torch
and see a woman Ascend the iron throat
throat had she been named joharis's Heir
Westeros might have fallen into chaos
even sooner in the end though the great
Council may have only prolonged the
inevitable
whether or not rhaenys could have saved
the realm for Wars Queen she has a
pretty clear chance to stop further
Bloodshed when she escapes on May lease
from the dragon pit in other words
[Music]
after bursting through the floor in her
roaring mounts rhaenice finds herself
staring down rhaenyra's entire rival
faction Otto Hightower sir Kristen Cole
Allison and all three of her children
with a single jacaris rhaenice could
have burned a lot of them and saved the
realm from the conflict that now seems
inevitable but she refuses and simply
flies away what is rhaenice show Mercy
at this moment when she already plans to
Ally herself with rhaenyra there are a
few possible explanations while she
disagrees with Allison's conviction that
women must remain in the background
rhaenys clearly has sympathy for the
green Queen also rhaenys might not have
fully chosen a side yet seeing rhaenyra
with her crown and loyal followers is a
powerful moment for the princess and it
might have taken that extra push to
convince her to take up arms killing a
whole royal family without a plan isn't
necessarily a great call one thing
that's for sure is that rainy's didn't
spare the green simply because she
abhors violence after all she must have
killed countless Innocents while
escaping the dragon pit vegar is the
largest living dragon in the world and
in the house of the Dragon season 1
finale she shows just how terrifying and
dangerous she can be with a single bite
she rips air acts and the Young Prince
luceras to Pieces establishing herself
as being in an entirely different League
from many of the show's other dragons
sure karaxi's Cyrax and melees are all
fearsome dragons but it might take all
three of them flying in tandem to even
have a shot at taking vegar down we're
talking about a dragon who survived
aegon's conquest and is still just as
deadly over a century later fortunately
for the blacks Damon is already hard at
work recruiting the remaining riderless
dragons to their cause beginning with
the next largest Beast after vegar
Dragonstone has 13 to therefore
I also have a score of eggs incubating
in the dragon Mound
during the final episode of House of the
Dragon season 1 Damon Targaryen Journeys
deep into the dragon mount the volcano
of Dragonstone in search of a new ally
knowing that the coming war between the
blacks and the greens will likely come
down to the respective dragons he aims
to recruit the riderless dragons who
nest on the island to his cause we see
him approaching the lair of the old
Dragon Burma Thor while singing of
Valyrian tomb and the dragon seems to
respond quite positively to it Belgian
fired throughout the cavern but leaving
Damon unburnt establishing contact with
Burma Thor is great for the blacks
especially since a creature is one of
the only dragons who might be able to
challenge vegar however there's one big
question that no one knows the answer to
yet who will ride him the only person in
rhaenyra's faction with Targaryen blood
and no dragon is Damon's young daughter
Reina who could be a suitable match
however it's also possible that a
non-targaryen could claim from Thor
Rainier's relationship with her Uncle
Damon is complicated to say the absolute
least though she's repeatedly shown
pursuing him throughout her life and
though incestuous relationships are
clearly not that Taboo in the world of
the show it's still hard not to see
their early Dynamic is deeply
problematic at best she chooses to be
with a man who killed his first wife in
order to advance his own station at
worst she was groomed from childhood to
love a deeply dangerous and treacherous
person Rainier is too smart not to
understand the kind of person Damon is a
person whose only real interest is in is
gaining more power however she seems to
believe that for some reason she's the
one person who's impervious to his Dark
Side she's different from asaria and
Lady Ria Royce from her own father who
Damon constantly fought with for
whatever reason be it ego or blindness
caused by love she seems to think he's a
weapon that could never be turned
against her in the season 1 finale
however we see that this isn't true
Damon shows a viciousness toward Rainer
when she starts to question his
warmongering and though he eventually
defers to her Authority it's clear that
he has his own intentions can rainera
really trust him to have her back when
things start to heat up
one of the larger mysteries in House of
the Dragon season 1 is What Becomes of
Leonard valarian rhaenyra targaryen's
first husband is believed by most of the
realm to be dead after his fight with
his lover Carl but that's far from the
truth in reality laner faked his dad
shaved his unmistakable Valyrian locks
and set off for Parts Unknown with Carl
and a boatload of money courtesy of
Damon and rhaenyra the implication is
that the two targaryens never intended
to kill Aynor as faking his death serves
multiple purposes it allows him to set
off on a life of adventure with his real
love and allows rhaenyra and Damon to
marry and it makes around fear rain era
a bit more via the rumor that she had
her husband murdered that's all
confusing enough and it doesn't even
touch on the matter of where Lenor might
be in all likelihood he's partying and
up with Carl in some far-flunk corner of
the free cities but what if something
happens what if he and Carl break up and
the good night decides to reveal the
truth to the world it's possible that
the former Prince is out of the story
for good but he could return under a
number of circumstances
an elusive yet powerful House of the
Dragon character is massaria the King's
Landing Madam who sets up a spy Network
within the red keep itself though she
lingers in the background for much of
season one messaria is always present
and she steps back into the spotlight
late in the season to reveal the
location of Prince aegon upon King
viserys's death as Lord Lara strong has
a spy network of his own he sees
massaria as a dangerous rival and moves
to Eliminator at the end of season one
we see an agent of Laris walking away
from osaria's burning brothel presumably
signaling her death but is she actually
out of the picture surely someone with
so much power in King's Landing can't be
relegated to an off-screen death masaria
has a whole system of agents and
Loyalists and it's likely that she would
have known about Lord lyrics's attack
ahead of time if masaria is alive she
may not show her face anytime soon she's
too smart for that
Allison Hightower is a curious case at
times both a tragic character and a vile
villain she stands opposite rhaenyra at
nearly every turn while it's easy to
condemn her for following her father's
power hunger schemes and defending her
sons during their many egregious crimes
Allison isn't such a simple character
from the time she was a child her father
pushed her into intimacy with King
viserys knowing full well that she might
become his Queen Alison hardly had a say
in this decision and once she starts
bearing the King's Children her sense of
Duty to her family prevents her from
even considering escape with her own son
Eamon now the murder of rhaenyra's son
lucerus it seems unlikely that Olive
branches will ever be extended and yet
it's still easy to see the regrets in
Allison's eyes her closest allies are
Laris strong who she seems to pay by
gratifying his foot fetish and Sir
Kristen Cole who's proven to be a
violent jealous and unpredictable man
perhaps reynis is right
you desire not to be free but to make a
window in the wall of your prison
perhaps The Dowager Queen really is too
far gone to ever find a life of real
happiness maybe just maybe Alison
Hightower still has some surprises up
her sleeve
like her father before her rhaenyra is
obsessed with a prophetic Song of Ice
and Fire aegon the conqueror's dream
foreseen the invasion of Westeros by the
white walkers
come the prince that was promised
and his will be the Song of Ice and Fire
the prophecy plays a huge part in House
of the dragon and it gives rhaenyra a
big picture reason to believe she must
be the one to sit on the Iron Throne
however foresight is rarely a simple
thing in fantasy and it remains to be
seen exactly how the Song of Ice and
Fire will play into the coming conflict
also the dragon would seem to be set in
the same Canon as its predecessor as it
even shares the same theme song but in
Game of Thrones the Targaryen prophecy
doesn't really play out the way you
think Arya Stark is the one who kills
the night King Jon Snow proves largely
ineffectual even after being brought
back from the dead and Daenerys goes
crazy and burns down King's Landing a
prophecy that plays out so chaotically
hardly seems like a good reason to put
countless innocent lives at risk but it
may be the final push Rainier needs to
declare war after her son's death of
course Daemon doesn't even believe in
the prophecy and it's possible that it
maybe lost the history amidst all the
fighting to come
foreign
[Music]